since 2009 the FDA has had the authority
to regulate the manufacturer
distribution and marketing of tobacco
products this move received praise from
Big tobacco because their products like
the traditional cigarette were
grandfathered in in 2016 the agency
determined that Vapes counted as tobacco
products eventually this would make it
nearly impossible to bring new brands of
e-cigarettes to Market so it's created
this perverse situation where the most
dangerous tobacco products on the market
are virtually untouched and the ones
that pretty much everyone agrees are far
far safer are getting taken off the
market now manufacturers have to
convince the FDA that sale of their
products is appropriate for the
protection of Public Health so far the
agency has determined that just three
brands meet the test all of which
contain tobacco flavored nicotine only
even though a majority of adult Vapors
prefer flavored options all the rest
according to the FDA are marketed
unlawfully and subject to enforcement
action at the fda's discretion